hey youtubers is charlie soap Marvel
released a big one sheet for Captain
America Civil War just showing up what
some of the teams are pretty much what
we expected in the russos we're talking
a lot about their spider-man character
in the tom hall and spider-man just to
start with spider-man stuff the big
question with this Tom Holland version
of spider-man the new trilogy is how is
he different from all the other versions
of spider-man from Andrew Garfield from
Tobey Maguire and what they said is they
try to take a much more personal
approach even more personal I think than
Sam Raimi's take on the character with
Tobey Maguire if you like the first
spider-man movie the first toby mcguire
movie was a much more personal
spider-man movie than the amazing
spider-man was but remember this is all
happening inside of a captain america
movie so totally this is much more in
line with Marvel's movies which I
actually think is perfect for the
spider-man character he's kind of like
the lawful good version of Deadpool
someone who doesn't kill people but
wisecracks with the best of them I
cannot wait to see him in a room with
Tony Stark Tony Stark is like the
spider-man of the Avengers the
wisecracker which is funny because
Spiderman was actually part of the
Avengers for a long time I know a lot of
you been asking where is he why haven't
they shown us pictures of him Kevin
foggy did confirm that they're finishing
CG on the suit that was a little while
ago so practically they just weren't
ready to put him in a trailer but I
think that they're probably end up doing
the Luke Skywalker thing where they just
they keep him out of all the marketing
materials so that he's a big surprise
when you finally see him in the movie
the Russos did say that their color
palette for the character was different
but they're just talking about the way
they shoot him so go back and watch some
of the Tobey Maguire spider-man the way
they shoot those movies the way he you
know he looks as he's moving through the
frame then look at Andrew Garfield
spider-man some of the differences there
and then watch Captain America winter
soldier and look at how the camera moves
and how the camera follows Captain
America and that like the opening 10
minutes of Winter Soldier where he's
jumping all over the ship trying to take
all those people down that's actually
some pretty bad ass spider man moves
it's just that Captain America is
bashing everyone with his shield if you
work clear though this version of
spider-man that we're going to see in
captain america civil war is about 15
years old freshman in high school so
that the new films will follow him
through each year of high school and
then we'll see what they do with the
character obviously he's going to be
part of infinity war but that's going to
happen way before the third spider-man
in the new trilogy happens but the
really cool thing about Sony
in Marvel sharing the character is is
that things that happen to spider-man in
Marvel movies will affect things that
happen in the spider-man solo films so
if he gets his ass handed to him by
Thanos an infinity war you will feel the
punch all the way in the next solo
spider-man film after that now the good
news is that the first solo spider-man
film is going to be out 2017 so we're
not going to have to wait too long to
find out what crossovers are going to
look like like something is going to
happen to him in civil war he'll learn
about the Avengers he'll get some gear
from Tony Stark we'll see how the first
solo spider-man film addresses that
within a year that to me is the most
exciting thing about spider-man in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is that
normally what you would see is they
might use them in captain america civil
war but when they get to the solo
spider-man film the director that movie
would be like well you know that's
somebody else's movie I don't want to
deal with the stuff that they did so I'm
just gonna tell my own story we're not
even going to address what happened so
there will be civil war aftershocks felt
in the first solo spider-man film we
just we just don't know how much moving
in a more civil war stuff look at this
big one sheet showing off what the teams
are now obviously there are more
characters in this but this is just
giving you an idea for who is on what
side what you're looking at here is the
New Avengers at each other's throats I
love the idea that we're going to see
ant-man versus black widow obviously
he's ant-man on this probably going to
be giant man in a big giant action set
piece we have vision versus Scarlet
Witch which is actually cannon to the
comics and it makes sense because of the
two most powerful members of the
Avengers Captain America versus Iron Man
no surprise there the one the one
surprise for me is Black Panther going
after the winter soldier he could be
team Iron Man at some point in the movie
but the way they pitched the character
so far is that he is the neutral third
party that doesn't really have any one
side maybe the winter soldier killed his
father at some point in history and they
actually did say that they're looking at
Ernie Hudson to play his father in the
solo Black Panther film moving up to the
corner here falcon vs war machine I'm
interested to see who takes war machine
down in this scene yeah I think Captain
America is going to go down hard but I
think they're going to take down war
machine before that happens just to kind
of even the blow so that no one side
walks away feeling like the clear winner
that's the whole point of Civil War to
show you how no one wins when Avenger
fights Avenger now go back to the left
side of this the curious thing here is
that Hawkeye is just drawing his bow not
fighting anybody in this so don't you
wonder if they're supposed to be a
spider-man in here
like the dead space right here is where
spider-man would normally go maybe
Hawkeyes going after him we don't really
know a lot about what's going on with
Hawkeye in the film only that there's
some concept art here based on this
cartoon with ant-man riding one of
Hawkeye's bows maybe to infiltrate the
Avengers facility or somewhere else
probably one of the best scenes to come
out of the cartoons so happy I will lose
my if they do this scene now the
Russos did post this image here it looks
like a spider-man teaser like they're
teasing his suit as if the eyes look
kind of like camera shutters that might
be a stark tech but just keep your eyes
peeled for viral spider-man marketing
when it comes to civil war stuff I don't
think we're going to see him any of the
official trailers but they might drop
some teasers let me know in the comments
though if spider-man is going to be
getting tech from iron man I mean it
kind of implies that he's going to be
team iron man do you think that he is
going to be iron spider do you want them
to do that or do you want him to have a
costume that's more authentic to the
original spider-man costume Kevin foggy
has said in the past that when we first
see spider-man he will be wearing a very
homegrown version of the costume like
something that teenager would come up
with so I'm expecting the first costume
to look a little bit more like Tobey
Maguire's t-shirt spider-man costume and
a lot of you guys have also been asking
me about the Doctor Strange trailer are
they going to attach it to Captain
America Civil War I would be willing to
bet money that they attach a Doctor
Strange teaser to captain america civil
war along with Star Wars rogue one they
finally drop some concept art of the
sanctum sanctorum so you kind of look
around here like you see the Cape you
see some of his artifacts and a lot of
people are thinking based on what Kevin
is saying that it's not the soul
gem that's inside the eye of agamotto
it's the time gem talked about
Doctor Strange manipulating
probabilities of being something like
that so people are thinking that might
be more of a hat tip to time travel but
it's still open to interpretation if
they do the time gem during Doctor
Strange that means they'll have to do
the soul gem and either guardians of the
galaxy two or thor ragnarok and it seems
like thor ragnarok would be the better
choice because of Odin's vault based on
what you guys have seen the rumors
you've heard do you think that this is
going to be the time gem or the soul gem
in case you guys haven't seen it i just
posted a new Deadpool teaser you can
click here to watch that and you can
click here for all my other captain
america civil war videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you